wo ist scarlett seit dem neunten
september wird die 26 jährige vermisst
die junge frau wollte mit dem rucksack
alleine den rund 190 kilometer langen
schluchtensteig im südschwarzwald
erwandern plötzlich ist sie spurlos
verschwunden mitte vergangener woche
bekam ihre familie noch ein paar fotos
über whatsapp dann kam plötzlich keine
nachrichten mehr
die letzte handyortung war ein tod muss
in der nähe des feldbergs in baden
württemberg dort wurde sie auch beim
einkaufen von einer überwachungskamera
gefilmt skaletz auto wurde im ort
stühling gefunden
dort beginnt der schluchtensteig
scarlett gilt als verlässlich sie ist 1
60 groß schlank hat einen roten
wanderrucksack und vermutlich ein
großzelt dabei sachdienliche hinweise
bitte bei der polizei melden und möchte
nun sprechen mit meinem kollegen
sebastian dränge denn er ist für uns im
schwarzwald sebastian was genau macht
diesen schluchtensteig so besonders für
wanderer aber eben auch so gefährlich
naja der schluchtensteig ist ein
absolutes natur paradies für wanderer
da geht einmal quer durch den ganzen
schwarzwald und man kommt hier vorbei an
aussichtspunkten an verfehlen aber man
geht eben auch durch tiefe schluchten
und wenn man hier einmal abseits der
wege unterwegs ist dann ist man
unberührter natur center unwegsames die
steilen hänge mit steigerung von über
70% und wenn man hier einmal ab und
standen dann wird man natürlich auch
sehr schwer gefunden
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren